наступний пункт програми слуга народу
створи створимо механізм народного вето
на щойно ухвалені закони де народне
вето де воно чотири роки вже пройшло
повноважень парламенту
більше мали бути зараз вибори вже якщо б
не воєнний стан До речі Нагадую що
вибори не можна проводити під час
воєнного стану якби Комусь не кортілося
і треба Україна має бути зосереджена на
чомусь одному або на перемозі над
ворогом або на перемозі на виборах маємо
бути зосереджені на перемозі над ворогом
але де виконана ця обіцянка далі
повернемо відповідальність чиновників за
незаконне збагачення хто ж у нас
покараний за це Покажіть нам одного